j'ai décollé je me suis arraché dans sa
Drôme et j'ai dit non de dieu ça y est
je suis parti je suis libre
en fait je suis pas libre du tout parce
que tu m'emmerdes encore tout le temps
voilà
[Applaudissements]
allez bonsoir bonsoir alors on est très
heureux que tu sois là ça nous fait
vraiment plaisir ainsi que notre
téléspectrice nous le demandait
mais ça nous force pas du tout alors
comment on est content vous devez faire
une surprise et tu sais que les missions
commence toujours par l'interview jumeau
alors soit tu t'auto interview soit
c'est quelqu'un qui interview et là on a
pensé à quelqu'un qui t'interview à ton
avis c'est qui
[Musique]
bonsoir
alors Julia
c'est pourtant au mois de mai mois de
mai c'est une fille ou un garçon comme
tu as déjà une fille tu as le choix du
roi bravo
alors est-ce que tu es prête à
interviewer ta mère bon on va essayer
bon tu vas prendre ma place et puis on
va y aller
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu te rappelles le temps que
tu as passé en avion pour venir me voir
en Italie quand j'étais petite fille
j'ai pas arrêté et bon ça a été toute ma
vie pendant 30 ans quoi où c'était pour
ton père ou pour moi enfin pour le
travail ou pour toi et je me souviens
d'une fois je m'en souviens et que
émotion je sais que à chaque fois tu me
disais toujours un pareil tu me disais
alors maman quand est-ce que tu arrives
et j'avais du travail beaucoup de
difficultés etc et bon finalement
j'arrivais
et c'était quand est-ce que tu pars et
je me souviens je savais que je devais
partir et un jour ta Nicolas américaine
c'est en dehors de Rome et un jour
je suis parti
était arrivé et puis tu m'as vu
et puis je suis parti de lendemain et
puis des années après
tu peux pleurer encore alors
j'ai lu comme ça par hasard ton petit
cahier comme ça
puis j'ai vu
on a fait un plaisir
je croyais qu'elle était partie puis
elle était restée
mais ce soir elle est partie et j'ai
pleuré
de l'absence de ton père que tu as
souffert
ta mère quand je te dis maman je suis
pas très à casserole
ouais c'est vrai un jour je vais à Rome
toujours comme ça toujours entre deux
avions entre 6 motocyclette et puis
j'arrive à Rome piano tu sais je
bon puis j'arrive à Rome et puis je
sonne à la maison personne répond alors
c'est la Rome quand même
temps et je vois la fenêtre qui s'ouvre
et elle me regarde
j'ai tout compris tu avais plus les
mêmes yeux
voilà alors je me souviens que je suis
reparti de lendemain toujours et je me
souviens quand j'ai décollé de Rome je
le faisais tellement de fois
et là j'ai quitté vraiment Rome
parce que vu que je ne vivais plus avec
ton père mais enfin on était très ami
donc je venais à Rome c'était vraiment
pour toi à partir du moment bon je
savais que tu étais toujours là je te
mets toujours mais je me suis dit bon
bah ça va je suis passé au rang des
oubliettes et j'ai décollé je me
rappelle j'ai décollé je me suis
arrachée
et j'ai dit non de dieu ça y est je suis
parti je suis libre
[Applaudissements]
merci merci à vous deux merci
encore
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu